et je voulais lui demander quelque chose
alors je dis mais monsieur et Monsieur
pas majeur je pense que on devrait
peut-être faire cette scène comme ça je
pense il s'est arrêté quand même à
regarder mais
[Musique]
alors Mylène tu es né
à Nice
et ton père était inspecteur général de
l'économie nationale et non ça rigole
pas là
et ta maman est d'origine russe complète
Claudia trouble nicova j'ai bien dit
tout ton enfance
tes études à 13 ans tu suis des parents
à Paris et puis là tu deviens tu adores
le piano quand j'ai commencé à 8 ans et
j'ai terminé à 16 ans le piano j'ai fait
8 ans de piano je voulais devenir
pianiste
je manquais de contact c'est une grande
solitude quand même là alors une jeune
fille de 16-17 ans toute seule devant
son piano 7 ans par jour il y a des
choses qui commencent à y passer par la
tête qu'il faut que ça devient très très
dur c'est facile à 8 ans avant 10 ans 11
ans c'est facile après c'est plus dur
vas-y sept ans tu commences à avoir des
étoiles
et je mais également je suis dans mes
trucs tu sais je commençais déjà avoir
l'esprit qui s'envolait de cinéma tu
regardes au cinéma
tu rêvais tu disais mon Dieu là alors tu
suis quand même des cours dans
dramatique parce que tu es quand même
très appliqué un professionnel du don tu
t'en vas pas comme ça au hasard
c'est Simon comme tout le monde bien sûr
Marie venduras c'était un personnage
elle est quand même jouer avec Sarah
Bernhardt alors elle était pleine
d'anecdotes et on était fascinés voyons
c'est c'est genre
tu faisais des photos
et puis elle aura 17 ans tu commences à
des enfants de l'amour de maugui c'est
ça
de l'amour
et puis ton premier grand rôle c'est à
Raymond Rouleau tu le dois d'aller
essentiel de Salem avec Yves Montand et
Simone Signoret excusez-moi du peu
c'est Michel Piccoli c'était Nicole
Courcel qui l'avait joué au théâtre
Sarah Bernard puis le rôle avait été
repris par Anne Doha
et puis toi au cinéma ça c'est quand
même une belle expérience ça c'est une
expérience fracassante mais en même
temps redoutable parce que quand tu
démarres avec un aussi beau personnage
il faut ramer pendant des années avant
de retrouver Anne équivalent et je ne
crois pas quand même très honnêtement à
part bon après le fait qu'il soit parti
dans la comédie dans les centres
premières des comédies et les faibles
femmes et les machins comme ça je ne
crois pas que j'ai retrouvé en 20 ans un
personnage de l'intensité de la force de
celui que j'ai eu dans les sorcières
donc c'était un cadeau un peu empoisonné
quelque part parce que tu il faut en
trouver d'autres après
exigeant au théâtre qui était à la fois
méticuleux qui était un bourreau de
travail parce qu'il dormait jamais
dans le film à 3h du matin alors qu'on
partait à 6 ou 7 heures en maquillage à
3h il y avait encore des conseils des
notes des machins et des maths tu feras
ça etc
ceci dit c'est assez stimulant parce que
quand on sort des roches le soir ce ne
sont pas des compliments ah comme c'est
bien que tu es merveilleuse et tout
c'est si vous me faites encore ça demain
ça ira mal tu vois
tout le monde est extrêmement
Bonjour tristesse d'après le roman de
Françoise Sagan avec ginsy Berg qui
était une amie
une fille formidable et il y avait deux
baraques
un jour parce que j'avais pas trop peur
de lui parce que j'étais pas très timide
à cet âge là et je voulais lui demander
quelque chose alors je disais mais
monsieur pas me dire je pense que on
devrait peut-être faire cette scène
comme ça je pense il s'est arrêté quand
même à regarder mais
pour la vie pour le reste de la vie
cette
société
puis tu joues dans deux films de Michel
de ville à cause à cause d'une femme
c'était un beau souvenir 62
l'appartement des filles 63 puis
Fantômas avec Jean-Marie qui est un
énorme succès d'une belle
puis en 68 tu te maries avec Maxime donc
est toujours ton mari mais et alors là
vous tous les deux vous vous êtes
producteur voilà oui c'est-à-dire que
bon lui il commençait moi je j'avais de
l'avance et puis on avait envie de vivre
ensemble et moi j'avais envie de tâter
de la production parce que ça m'avait
toujours énervé sur les plateaux je
posais des questions on me disait toi ça
ne te regarde pas et ça ça m'énervait
alors j'ai commencé à apprendre cet
autre aspect il me suis rendu compte à
quel point c'était le pied
qui aime le cinéma et qui veut essayer
de tout comprendre et de te connaître
sans être et puis il faut quand même
avoir à côté un peu marchand de tapis
quelque part il faut aller vendre sa
salade alors toi quand tu es passionné
par un sujet tu la vends mal tu as
celle-là elle parce que tu as tellement
envie de la faire que les gens savent
bien
alors c'est très dur alors donc je suis
pas un bon producteur je peux quand même
rester un bon promoteur c'est-à-dire
dénicher une histoire l'aimer allez la
défendre et une fois que je l'ai bien
défendu et trouver des gens qui
s'intéressent et même faire le premier
scénario à ce moment là je repasse
l'ensemble à quelqu'un qui va aller se
battre à ma place toujours la campagne
non je suis rentré à Paris avant tu
habitais la campagne
parce que vous viviez avec plein
d'animaux alors ça ça paraît pas étrange
parce que vivre à la campagne des
animaux moi j'ai des chiens des chiens
des canards des poulets mais vous vous
aviez des bêtes un peu étranges des
serpents on a eu un beau à on a eu deux
trois mangouste on a élevé une chouette
dans notre chambre une grande chouette
qui vivait avec nous c'est la nuit vous
regardez
venez jouer sur le lit avec son petit
animal en plus on a eu la joie avec son
animal en plus
j'ai ouvert la fenêtre sur la nuit j'ai
mis à manger pendant 8 jours elle est
elle est rentrée le matin elle est
ressortie avec lui il a beau jour elle
est partie
et le serpent il dormait aussi dans la
maison dormait sur le radiateur dans un
petit panier en osier les mangoustes se
foutaient complètement du serpent parce
qu'elles étaient bien nourries quand
elles sont bien nourris elle ne tue pas
les serpents et tu quand elles ont faim
et puis on a eu jusqu'à 18 chats mais ça
c'est moins intéressant mais c'était
quand même assez pénible pour les
vacances
tout le temps à partir de l'âge de 8 ans
il a commencé à avoir ce qu'il en a pris
les gosses des Snake femme alors il a eu
ses Snake farm il a commencé à attraper
les serpents partout et maintenant à son
âge l'homme adulte il continue à
attraper les serpents partout il y a 2
ans on était en Amérique il est parti
avec un bâton il a revenu avec un
crotale ça reprend un sonnette énorme en
mettant ses mains sous les pieds
jamais été piqué et alors là vous l'avez
ramené en France tu m'as raconté ça
c'était un autre que j'ai ramené l'été
quand même plus inoffensif il avait pas
parce que ça représente la trouille et
on a ramené à une espèce d'énorme
serpent qu'on avait trouvé en Arizona et
comme il est un peu [ __ ] quand même il
m'avait dit tu le mets dans ton sac et
puis tu passes à la douane tu es une
femme ça aurait l'air d'un sac d'une
ceinture c'est pas grave et tout ça
est-ce que je suis retourné dans le 747
New York Paris j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
quand même en disant si le serpent fout
le corps dans l'avion ça a quand même
être un grand drame c'est rien passé moi
j'ai pas dormi mais après j'ai passé
devant la dame qui a ouvert mon sac qui
a dit qu'est-ce que c'est que ça je dis
rien la ceinture après il est passé dans
les rayon X après il est passé devant
les douaniers et je vais je te jure
quand je suis
[Musique]